Camilla now for the first time looking
absolutely magnificent Amanda
totally magnificent yes unattended by
her
page boys and her page boys
one of them I believe is Freddie her
grandson apparently
um he is a huge Tottenham Hotspur fan
and we've been we're being told by his
father Tom that he has his Tottenham
Hotspur strip on underneath his page boy
outfits that are very modern that's
brilliant he needs it today yeah and we
see the king as well uh arriving for uh
the first time heading in to The Abbey
uh one wonders what must be going
through his mind right now he was here
70 years ago where of course when he was
just four years old
um to witness the coronation of his
mother Princess Anne the Princess Royal
deemed to have been too young at the
time to attend but we have seen I think
Louis George and Charlotte are all here
as well as we see images of the king
foreign
[Music]
Princess of Wales
we will file past and we'll take their
places under the lantern
[Music]
for the king wearing the Crimson Rover
estate
is going to join this procession which
has now the chapter of Westminster
and the Archbishop of Canterbury led by
the Canterbury cross and also the dean
of Westminster
princess Wales and their robes of the
order of the Garter and the Royal
Victorian order respectively
the king awaits while his grandson just
the back there on the left
Prince George Wales
as the
Queen Mary crime carried there by the
Duke of Wellington to be placed upon
Queen Camilla's head after she's been
anointed by the Archbishop shortly it
was made for
Queen Mary for the coronation in 1911.
just ahead there
on the left holding the
except with the cross achieved general
staff
and on the right carrying the scepter
with the dove
the Duke of a clue on the left there
carries the scepter with the cross
and the Earl Marshall of England Duke of
Norfolk
with
all the other items of the regalia the
Spurs
chief of Defense staff
as the Lord High Constable he was
appointed at seven o'clock this morning
The Honorable Corps of gentlemen at Arms
the closest body card to the
kit now leading
the scepter with the dove of King Lim
Mercy
the orb
of globe or Cosmos Samantha by the cross
and send Edward's crime being carried
by the Lord High steward
Who was appointed also at seven o'clock
this morning an ancient great officer of
state so powerful that they can only be
created for the day of coronation
and as is tradition
the playing of I was glad when they said
unto me
set to the music of Hubert Parry as
green console's procession will join in
and head
to the lantern of this Abbey
and when the king and queen are making
their way into the choir
the scholars of Westminster Will shout
out the vibans
in Latin saying God save
Queen Camilla and God save King Charles